Welcome to deep reinforcement
learning or CS224R.
I'm really excited to be
teaching it again this quarter.
My name is Chelsea.
I am the instructor
of the course.
I'm an assistant professor
here at Stanford.
I do research on reinforcement
learning, robotics,
and language models, and
a variety of other topics.
So the plan for today.
So we're going to be
covering the course
goals and some logistics.
Hopefully this will
be fairly short
because all this information
is available online.
After that, we'll
be talking about why
study deep
reinforcement learning
and actually get into some
technical content on modeling
behavior and
reinforcement learning.
The key learning goals
for today is what even
is deep reinforcement learning?
How do we go about actually
representing behavior in a way
that we can optimize behavior?
And how do we formulate a
reinforcement learning problem?
So what do we mean by deep
reinforcement learning?
So first, for
reinforcement learning,
we mean decision-making
problems.
And these are problems
where a system
needs to make multiple
decisions based
on a stream of information.
So it'll observe and
then take an action
based on that
observation, and then
observe again and
take another action.
And we'll be studying
those of problems
as well as the solutions
to those problems,
and that includes things like
imitation learning, model-free
and model-based reinforcement
learning, offline
and online reinforcement
learning, multi-task
and meta reinforcement
learning, as well as
a little bit of a extra
focus on reinforcement
learning for large
language models,
and reinforcement
learning for robots.
So that's the crux
of reinforcement
learning aspect of the course.
And we'll be emphasizing
solutions that
scale to deep neural networks.
And we'll be spending
a lot less time
on solutions that don't pertain
to deep neural networks.
Now, how does deep RL differ
from other machine learning
topics?
So hopefully a lot of
you have some experience
with machine learning.
And oftentimes in
machine learning,
you'll have some
input/output pair x, y.
And you'll have a bunch
of these in some data set,
and then your goal
is to learn something
that can map from x to y.
And another thing
is that we typically
assume in these data sets is
that these data points are
sampled from some
distribution and are
sampled independent
and identical way
from that distribution.
And this is actually where
reinforcement learning
differs quite a bit.
So in supervised learning
we have labeled data.
We learn this function.
We're directly told
what to output.
We're pulled what the answer
is for that given input,
and the inputs
are i.i.d sampled.
Now, in reinforcement
learning, the picture
is a little bit different.
So ultimately our goal
is to learn behavior.
And we'll actually
use different notation
to refer to inputs and outputs.
So specifically our goal will be
to map from states to actions.
And we'll refer to the function
that we do that mapping as pi.
And unlike in
supervised learning,
we're not going to be directly
told what the answer is.
Our goal will actually be to
learn this behavior from much
more indirect feedback.
And so in
reinforcement learning,
the goal is to learn this
behavior pi of a given s.
And this will be
from experience,
and actually
experience often drawn
from the policy
that you're learning
or this function
that you're learning.
And the data is not
going to be sampled
from a single distribution.
It's actually going to be
sampled in a way that actually
depends on the policy
or the function
that you're currently learning.
So these are the
two big differences.
And what I mean by
behavior is this
could include motor control
like controlling your robot.
It could include a chatbot that
is interacting with a person.
It could be playing a game.
It could be driving a car.
It could be an agent
that's interacting
with the web and a wide
range of other domains.
So that's how reinforcement
learning differs
from typical machine learning.
We don't have the ability
to cover everything
in deep reinforcement
learning, and so we're
going to try to focus
on the core concepts
behind deep reinforcement
learning methods,
so that you can then use those
core concepts to understand
more advanced methods,
should you choose
to dive deeper into the topic.
We'll also focus on
implementation of algorithms
to get to the point where you
feel comfortable implementing
algorithms yourself.
And we'll give examples in
robotics, control, and language
models, especially in
lecture and in projects,
but a lot of the techniques
will generalize more broadly,
and also just to focus
on topics that we
think are the most useful and
the most exciting to cover.
If you're interested in more
theory and other applications
that are beyond some of
these, CS234 can also
be an excellent choice.
And then the core
goal is really to be
able to understand and
implement existing and emerging
methods in deep reinforcement.
Cool.
So why study deep
reinforcement learning?
I'll list out a
number of things here,
and then we'll dive into
each one a little bit more.
So one we already
talked about is going
beyond supervised example.
And there's a lot of scenarios
where AI model predictions have
consequences.
And if we want to take into
account those consequences,
then we need a
framework for thinking
about those consequences
and how to optimize
the behavior with respect
to those consequences.
So for example, if you listen to
music on Spotify, for example,
and the Spotify algorithm is
recommending a song for you
to play or even actually
just playing it directly
for you, that recommendation
has consequences
such that the next time
it recommends a song,
it probably shouldn't
recommend the same song,
or it might want to also
stay within the same genre,
and so forth.
And so if we want to think
about developing AI systems
that can take into account
those consequences,
that's what deep reinforcement
learning allows us to do.
There's also scenarios
where direct supervision
isn't available.
So for example, if you have a
coding assistant like Cursor
or Copilot, and you want
to give it feedback saying,
did a great job there
or did a poor job there,
that supervision
is not the output.
It's a more indirect
supervision.
And learning from that
indirect supervision or really
any objective can be formulated
as a reinforcement learning
problem.
So it's a lot more flexible
than supervised learning.
Reinforcement learning is
also widely used and deployed
in a number of
performant AI systems.
Also learning from
experience, in my opinion,
seems fundamental
to intelligence.
And so just from a
philosophical level
in terms of building
intelligent machines,
figuring out how
to actually develop
algorithms that can learn
from their own experience
seems pretty
fundamental to that.
And it's fundamental to
be able to actually make
discoveries of new things rather
than just mimicking the data.
And then lastly, there's
also some pretty exciting
open research problems
as well, and so
it makes it a pretty exciting
area to do research on.
And then lastly, last weekend,
I was telling a friend
that I was making slides on
why study deep reinforcement
learning, and how I was
making several slides on it,
and they were like, this
question doesn't seem very hard.
The answer is just one
million in total compensation
from OpenAI.
So maybe if you're not
motivated by 1 through 4,
this can be some motivation.
So diving into beyond
supervised learning.
Decision-making
problems are everywhere
and can't be directly
formulated supervised learning.
Any AI agent is
captured by this.
Also if you want your
AI system to interact
with people like chatbots
or recommenders or scenarios
where decisions will affect
future outcomes or observations,
these feedback loops, these are
reinforcement learning problems.
And then yeah, like I mentioned
before, if you don't have labels
in your objective,
isn't just accuracy
or it's nondifferentiable.
These are scenarios where
reinforcement learning
is useful.
Now, I mentioned
that deep RL is used
in a variety of different
performance systems.
What am I talking about there?
Two examples of legged robots
that have learned behavior
with reinforcement
learning, in this case,
reinforcement learning
and simulation and then
transferred to the real world.
So you can get some cool stuff
like puppy robots and dancing
humanoids.
And these are actually real
robots in the real world.
Policies that are trained with
deep reinforcement learning.
Beyond legged
robots and dancing,
you can also get robots that can
manipulate with arms to do tasks
using, in this case,
imitation learning,
but still within the
scope of this course.
So the left is a robot that is
unloading laundry and folding
the laundry.
On the right is a robot that
can fold some simple origami.
So some pretty cool stuff you
can do with these methods.
You can also learn to
play complex games.
So several years ago, DeepMind
used deep reinforcement learning
to train a system to
play the game of Go,
and it actually
defeated Lee Sedol,
which was really impressive
in its own right.
And another really
cool thing about it
was coming back to this
discovery challenge
of AI systems.
There was this move
that surprised everyone
that was an expert in Go.
It was called Move 37, and
it discovered a strategy
that humans previously
hadn't thought of before.
And so this is an example of
how reinforcement learning can
be a tool to discover
new solutions.
And this might be
useful beyond games.
But if we want to, for example,
discover curious diseases
or discover things that
require experimentation,
it provides a tool for
doing those things.
And it's not just
robots and games,
so nearly all modern language
models use some form of RL
for post-training, especially
for more advanced reasoning
as well.
There's also research on traffic
control using reinforcement
learning and finding
ways to insert cars
into human-driven cars in order
to increase the throughput
on different roads.
Research on training
generative models
with reinforcement learning.
In this case, for example,
trying to make the generations
adhere to a particular prompt.
So what these are
showing is on the left.
If you ask the base
generative model
to make a picture of a
dolphin riding a bike,
it'll give you this, which
is not a very good picture.
And then you can optimize it
through reinforcement learning
to get a picture that
is actually following
the prompt more effectively,
and likewise for other prompts
as well.
And this also is being
used for Chip design.
This is a paper
that designed chips
that are used in Google's
production TPU, which is also
pretty useful.
Yeah.
Great.
So those are a few examples.
There's a number of others
that I didn't cover as well.
The next thing that I mentioned
in terms of studying deep RL
seems somewhat fundamental
to intelligence.
And for this, I want to tell
a little bit of a story which
is that right after I
graduated undergrad,
I joined a lab that was looking
at reinforcement learning
for robots.
And right next to where I was
sitting was this robot here.
And oftentimes
there was a post-doc
in the lab who was running
experiments with reinforcement
learning, and so I would
look over at the robot
and it would be doing
things like this.
And the thing that
really fascinated me
about watching this
robot is you can actually
see it learning over time.
And at the beginning it
knew nothing about how
to, for example, insert and
assemble these two parts
of a toy airplane,
and at the end,
it's actually able to do
it quite performantly.
So this is really, really cool.
You can actually see it
learning from its own experience
in the real world.
So essentially
reinforcement learning
enables this ability
to get better
with practice that isn't present
in other machine learning
systems.
Now, there is one
caveat to this,
which is that this particular
robot had its eyes closed.
It wasn't using a
camera, essentially,
and that seemed like a really
fundamental limitation to me.
And so I actually then worked
with the postdoc on a follow-up
project with cameras, and it
was able to, in this case,
then, learn in
the real world how
to insert the red block
into the shape sorting cube.
And again here,
with experience is
able to get better and better
as it practices the task over
and over again.
And then after the
learning process,
it's still learning,
still improving.
It ends up getting
a success rate.
I think around 95% or
100% success at the end.
And then I can
hold the block out,
or at least a
young version of me
can hold the block
out for the robot,
and the robot can
then put the red block
into the same currency.
Now, these are
very simple tasks.
This is in some ways
a long time ago,
and now we have robots that
can fold laundry and do dancing
and so forth.
But one of the
reasons why I like
showing these videos
is they really
show the reinforcement
learning process
in the real world
and the ability
to improve with practice.
At the same time, there's also
a ton of exciting research
problems that are open.
And so if you're someone who's
excited about doing research,
there's challenges like,
how does this robot learn
to represent what is
good for the task.
Or how does an agent
generalize its behavior,
not just to one scenario, but
to many different scenarios?
And can we apply such
a system at scale
with large, diverse data sets
and transfer from other tasks
and other goals?
And can we use reinforcement
learning to learn long horizon
tasks like cooking a meal or
solving a really hard math
problem?
And can robots practice
fully autonomously?
And for this last point,
I showed you some videos
of reinforcement learning.
That's not actually
always what it looks like.
So sometimes if you run
reinforcement learning on robot,
it looks more like this, where
the robot is trying to hit
the hockey puck into the goal.
And every time the
robot attempts the task,
it then needs to start
over and re-attempt it,
and the robot doesn't actually
know how to undo the task.
And this is my
friend Yevgen. You
might notice that
Yevgen is actually
doing more work than
what the robot is
doing, which doesn't quite seem
like the right way of doing
things.
And it's not practical to
collect a lot of data this way.
And along all these topics,
these are some of the topics
that we'll be covering
in this course as well.
So we'll be talking
about reward learning
and how to represent
different rewards.
We talk about offline
RL, multitask RL,
and meta-RL, hierarchy, and
reasoning, and reset-free RL
as well.
Cool.
So any questions on why deep
RL is interesting to study?
Yeah.
So the question was, how
do you learn a reward
when the robot is learning
in the real world?
And in that particular example,
we represented the reward
as the distance between--
or the negative distance between
the position of the object
and the goal position
of the object.
And you might have noticed that
in the case with the shape cube,
the robot was actually
holding the cube,
and so that meant
that we could actually
measure using the
robot arm position
where the cube was as well.
Now, you can't do
this in practice.
In many scenarios it's
specific to that task.
And in the hockey example,
there was actually
a mocap marker on
the hockey puck
that measured where it is in--
yeah, where it is in the room.
And in general, it's very hard.
And that's why reward
learning is necessary
in order to solve the problem
in a more general way.
Good question.
So now let's dive into modeling
behavior and reinforcement
learning.
So we need to figure out how to
represent experience as data.
So as the robot
was practicing, we
need to think about
how we can actually
represent what was captured
in that video as data
to learn from.
And so here's another
example of a robot
learning in the real world.
We might also want to think
about how to represent text
from a chatbot, for example.
In either of these cases we
need to think about experience
that the agent collect.
How do we actually
write that down as data?
So the way that we do that,
typically in reinforcement
learning, is first we'll think
about the state of the world.
And we'll use S to denote the
current state of the world.
And for example, in
the case of the robot,
the state of the world might
be the position of the arm
and the position of the towel
and the position of the hook.
Or if you don't have access
to information about the towel
directly, it might
just be an image
captured from the robot's
camera and the position
of the joints of the arm
if you have access to that.
Now, you can't always
have direct access
to the state of the world,
and so sometimes we'll
refer to an
observation O, and use
observations instead of states.
And the difference between
observations and states
is that with
observations it may not
capture all of the information
you need to make a decision.
And you might actually need to
think about past observations
that you've seen before.
So for example, for a chatbot,
if you're interacting with it,
you can think of the
observation at a given time
step as the most recent message
that you sent to that chatbot.
And then that most
recent message
doesn't tell the
chatbot everything
it needs to know about what
the next response should be.
And so what you
need is you actually
need to give it the history
of past observation, not just
the current observation, in
order to make a decision.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about this state observation
distinction in a couple slides.
So this is capturing what
the agent is observing.
Now, we also need to capture
how it's taking actions, how
it's actually making decisions.
And we'll refer to those
decisions as actions.
And we'll use the letter
a to denote actions.
And then in terms of
a given interaction
with the environment, we will
think of that as a trajectory.
So that will be a sequence
of states and actions
or a sequence of
observations and actions.
So this is one way to
represent behavior,
and this will then result in
a data set of trajectories
rather than a data
set of xy pairs.
And then we need to think
about what is actually
the goal of the task, and that's
where reward functions come in.
And reward functions
are essentially
telling us how good is a
given state and action.
In many cases, the
reward function
will only depend on the state.
And for example,
it might tell you
how close is the
towel to being hung,
or is the towel hung or not.
Or in the case of a teapot it
might be, how happy is the user?
Or did they give me a
thumbs up or a thumbs down?
And then this experience
is the trajectory,
and that trajectory might be
augmented with the rewards.
So each time you
roll out the policy,
you'll get some
data in this form.
Let's talk a little bit more
about states and observations
first.
We can then think about states
and actions, is in some ways
a lot like a Markov chain.
So they will have the
first state of the world.
This is, for example,
in the robot case,
let's say the towel is on
the table and there's a hook,
and the goal is to put
the towel on the hook.
This first state is like the
robot in some neutral position
and the towel on the table.
And then the robot
will take some action.
This is like moving its arm
to a particular location.
And that action and
the current state
will inform what
the next state is.
And then from there--
maybe the towel is
in the same position
if the robot was just
moving in free space,
or maybe the towel is moved.
And the robot will then
take another action,
and it will move its arm again.
And the states and actions will
then inform the next state.
Now, one crucial
thing here is that we
can think of how the environment
is changing under what's
called a dynamics function.
So you have P of
S3 given S2 and a2.
This is the dynamics
of the world.
This is, does the arm
actually move in space,
and how does the
towel move in space?
as a function of where it was
before and what the robot did.
And the crucial
thing to notice here
is that S3 only
depends on S2 and a2,
and it doesn't depend on S1.
And so there's no S1 in this
probability distribution.
And essentially, S3 is going
to be independent of S1
if you condition on S2.
And this independence property
is called the Markov property.
And it's one of the things
that actually ends up
being very useful in
reinforcement learning.
So it allows you to
break up the problem
into these scenarios
where you don't
have to worry about
all the dependencies
that come before it.
Now, if you have observations
instead of states,
then things look a
little bit different.
And the way that we can
think about observations
is the observation is a
function of this current space,
and it may not contain all the
information that's in the state.
And so the observation at
any given point in time.
For completeness we'll
draw each of them here.
And then if you
don't have access,
if you can't observe the
space, that means now that O2--
or sorry, O3, it's not just
a function of O2 and a2,
it's actually also a function
of O1 if you cannot observe
the same.
Cool.
So on the slide, we can
think about this model
where we have these dynamics.
We don't know how the
world is going to evolve.
We can't predict the future.
Under these dynamics
are unknown.
And these dynamics are
independent of St minus 1 ,
in this case, and that's
known as the Markov property.
Any questions on that?
Yeah.
So the question is, in practice,
how many past observations
do we need to infer the state?
It is heavily domain dependent.
Yeah.
Heavily domain dependent.
In a lot of robotics
examples, you
can often get away with just
using the current sensor
observations.
But it depends a lot on
what the sensors are like.
If you have tactile sensors,
for example, those oftentimes
don't contain as
much information
as vision observation,
for example.
You have no idea when
you're not making contact.
And then once you
make contact you
know there's a lot more
partially observable
than an image, for example.
But then if you have the
images in addition to that,
then that gives you a more
complete representation.
Yeah.
So why is the reward
function a function
of both the state and the
action and not just the state?
One example of this is--
we can go back to
a robotics example.
So say that you are
a humanoid robot,
and you're trying to
learn how to walk,
and maybe one natural reward
function is just how much
forward progress have you made.
So where is your body, and that
would be dependent on the state.
One scenario where you
might want the action
is that scenario
where if you don't
want to be using too much
energy because you don't want
to be like tensing up all
the motors, for example,
or I guess--
muscles make more sense.
But if you don't want to
be pushing too much energy
into your motors, then you'll
want to depend on the actions
as well, and you
could basically have
some penalty on how
much torque you're
putting through the motors.
So that's one example.
In many cases, you can
just depend on the state.
But there are some
examples where
you want to penalize
taking too much action.
Yeah.
So the question is, if
the observation is only
part of the state, then why
does a future observation not
independent of
past observations?
And the reason for that is
that the-- we can actually
go back to the tactile example.
So say that you make contact
and then you stop making contact
and then you make contact
again, in that case, the most
immediate past observation
doesn't actually tell you
that much information
about the current state,
whereas this observation
actually tells you
a lot more information
about the state.
And so then O3, you
can actually figure out
more about O3 when you
don't just condition on O2,
but also condition on O1.
And there's also a way for folks
familiar with graphical models
to actually think about.
If you marginalize
out these variables,
you'll actually see that
in the graphical model.
I don't want to go
into that today,
but that's another way
that you can see this.
Correct.
So yeah.
If you were to estimate
and predict O3,
then you need to use
past observations.
But the actual observation
in this graphical model
is dependent on the state which
might be unobserved or unknown.
Cool.
So let's walk through
a couple examples
of what this might look like.
So in the robotics
case, the state
could include three
different things.
One would be the RGB images
from any cameras on the robot,
the positions of all
the joints of the robot,
and the velocities
of the joints.
And so this is a fairly
common state representation
for a robot system.
And the images would be actually
a different dimensionality
than the positions, and so you
might need to actually configure
your neural network
in a way that
can accept those different
dimensionalities.
The action would then be the
commanded next joint position.
So how are you going
to move your joint?
If your joint's
currently at 90 degrees,
maybe you'll try to
move it to 92 degrees.
The trajectory then would be a
sequence of states and actions.
So a sequence of videos--
or a sequence of images,
which is essentially
a video, a sequence
of joint positions,
and a sequence of command
and joint positions.
Now, what does that
sequence actually entail?
Typically what we do is
we'll discretize time
and the sequence will then,
for example, be at 20 Hertz.
So your video will be
20 frames per second.
And you'll have
joint observations
20 times per second.
And you'll also have commanded
actions 20 times per second.
I always found this a
little bit unintuitive
when I first learned it
because, as a person,
I don't really think about
making a decision 20 times
every second, but it is
oftentimes the most practical
way to represent data and
behavior on physical systems,
like robots.
And then for the
reward function,
there's a few things
you could use here.
One could be one, if the towel
is on the hook in state S and 0.
Otherwise you could
also have some sort
of penalty on the torques that
you're applying on the action
or something like that.
So that's a robot example.
Now let's go to a
chatbot example.
So here the
observation-- we likely
wouldn't have a compact
state representation,
so we be using observations.
And the observation could be
the user's most recent message.
The action would be the
chatbots next message.
So this would be potentially
a sentence or a paragraph.
It potentially could
actually be very large.
And then you can think of the
trajectory as the conversation
trace, so the history of
the current conversations.
And unlike in the
robotics example,
this won't necessarily be at
a fixed 20 Hertz frequency.
It might take longer
for a user to respond
or something like that.
So this is an example of how
trajectories might vary in terms
of how time is represented.
So in the first case, time
is represented as a 20th
of a second.
Whereas in the second
case, time is represented
as when the user responds next.
And then as an example reward.
Maybe it's 1 if the user
gives an upvote, negative 10
if the user gives
a downvote, and 0
if there's no user feedback.
These are examples of how we can
set up reinforcement learning.
Now I would like to ask you
to formulate a reinforcement
learning problem.
And in particular,
I'd like you to define
the state or observation, the
action trajectory and reward,
for either one of
these three examples
or choose your own example.
Yeah.
So in this example,
basically the question is,
why would this be an
observation persistent state?
It could actually be formulated
both ways, potentially.
It depends on the details
of the sensor measurement.
So as one example, if
your sensors are just
looking like a LiDAR, like
the current depth around you,
and a picture of
what's in front of you,
maybe something
along those lines,
one thing that that
would be missing
is how fast the cars
are moving around you,
the velocity of the cars.
And that's probably quite
important for what's
going to happen in the future
if it stops versus moving
at 60 miles per hour.
Now, you could potentially try
to include a history of LiDAR
information to get that
velocity information
and then represent your state
as a three-second history,
for example.
And this will represent a
theme which is typically
to handle observations.
We'll use a little
bit of history
and then that can form
your state representation.
So it's a little bit ambiguous
in this particular case.
And yeah, it comes
down to the details.
Yeah.
So the question is,
in the robot example,
if the reward is 1, if
it's on the hook and 0
otherwise, how do
you actually learn?
because if you don't actually
ever do that at any point,
then you'll have very
little supervision signal.
You'll just have 0
reward all the time.
And so in that particular video,
we actually showed the robot
how to do it a couple
times as initialization,
and that helped it with
what we'll call exploration.
And if you have
very sparse rewards,
rewards that have
very little signal
and are not nicely
shaped towards the goal,
then usually that data might
be important for jumpstarting
the reinforcement
learning problem.
Cool.
Yeah.
So if folks couldn't
hear that, you'd
have the state being
something like the HTML
and the URL, information
about the web page.
And where you're at, the action
would be interacting with it,
and the reward would be whether
or not some task was completed.
Yeah.
So the question is, is basically
everything in observation
because sensors
may not be perfect?
So you could always
choose to model something
as an observation if you're
worried about sensor noise
or something like that.
There are, in some
ways, potentially
large downsides to it if you
need to add a lot of history.
And so sometimes we will
approximate something
as the state, even if it
might be lacking information.
Maybe, I don't know, once every
10,000 times the sensor fails
and gives you a black image
or something like that.
Even though that would
technically be an observation
case, you might still use
it as a state representation
because of how it
affects the algorithms.
So if I understand
correctly, you're asking--
for observations, it could
either be everything currently
or it could be a delta from
the previous observation.
Yeah.
It would come down to different
trade-offs oftentimes.
If you are going to be
including a lot of history,
then compressing
it by using deltas
could potentially
make a lot of sense.
But once we get into
policies, maybe it'll
also become more clear.
So now that we've
talked about formulating
the reinforcement
learning problem,
let's talk about actually
representing behavior.
So we want to map typically
from states or observations
to actions.
And to do that, we'll use
what's called a policy.
And this policy
will often use pi
to denote a policy or
basically almost always use pi.
And this can just
be a neural network.
In this case, it's a
convolutional neural network.
It could be a transformer.
It could be a simple fully
connected neural network.
It could be a linear function.
And this is going to be
mapping from the states
or observations, or the sequence
of observations to actions.
We'll use typically
theta to refer
to the parameters of
that neural network
that you're trying to learn.
And so then when you're actually
using a policy to take actions,
we'll then observe a
state, take an action,
and observe a next state.
And when we take
actions we're actually
going to be sampling
from our neural network.
So we'll actually be
running a forward pass
through the neural network
to select an action,
and then execute that
action in the real world
and observe the next state.
Cool.
And so the result of this
process is a trajectory.
And when we're using a policy
to generate this trajectory,
we often refer to it as
a rollout or an episode.
You can think of it as--
one episode of learning
is like one attempt
and then trying it
again and again.
And I guess the terminology
rollout is in the sense
that you're sequentially
going policy dynamics,
and so you're rolling out this
process to create a trajectory.
Great.
And then if you only
have observations
and you don't have
states, the solution
is to give your policy
memory, and so you can
pass in multiple observations.
Whereas if you only
give it a state,
you actually don't have
to give it any memory,
and you can just give
it as input state.
This is very convenient
because if you
have a large amount of memory,
it will take up a lot of memory
on your computer or on your GPU.
But if you only
have observations,
then you have, in some
ways, no choice but
to provide that
memory to the policy.
And for this you may use
sequence models, for example.
In language models, you're going
to be using sequence models that
use the previous observations.
Yeah.
So the question is, is T
like the current time step
or is it general from
the beginning to the end?
So this capital T,
I'm using to denote
the end of the trajectory, so
the length, the number of states
and actions in a trajectory.
And then t, I'm referring
to a given time step
and generalizing
it so that you can
think about this as happening at
all time steps from lowercase t
equals 1 to lowercase
t equals capital T.
Is it ever useful
to condition it
on both the observation
and the state?
So in this case, the state
has strictly more information
than the current
observation, and so it
isn't useful to
add the observation
if the state is truly the
state that captures everything.
So if we go back to this
diagram, if we have states,
then we only need to
provide the current state.
Whereas if we have observations,
that's where adding history
is helpful.
So it's a distinction between
states and observation.
Why is it having history of
observation, [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah.
So basically the
past observations
will help give you more
information about what S1 is.
And so if you only
have observations
and you don't know what the
underlying state of the world
is--
as another example
in language modeling,
if you are having a
conversation with a user,
each thing that the user says
is a different observation,
and the past observations
will actually
tell you a lot about what the
current state of the world is.
So if their first
question was like,
can you write this
piece of code to me?
And then you maybe
wrote some piece of code
and they gave you some feedback,
it's actually very important
to include all those past
observations to actually capture
the full state of the world.
I mean, that might not
be true in all cases.
But in many, many cases,
the previous observations
will also be useful
for the current state.
So there also could
be scenarios where
you might want a two-stage
process, one where you first
infer the state, and then a
second process where you then
predict the action
from that state.
If you have some idea
for a good representation
for the underlying state,
then that information
could be useful in trying to
model the underlying state.
In other cases,
it's simple as just
to go straight from
observations side.
OK.
Moving on a little bit.
So we've talked about
states actions policies.
What is actually the goal
of reinforcement learning?
So our goal is to
maximize reward.
And so if we have
a trajectory, we
don't want to just optimize for
the reward at one time step,
but we want to optimize
for having reward
across the entire trajectory.
And so we can represent this as
maximizing the sum of rewards.
Now, one thing that came
up is that this is actually
not a deterministic quantity.
So if you have a
policy and you're then
executing that policy in the
world, the reward that you get
isn't always going to
be the same every time
you run your policy.
And so a question for you.
Why is this not a
deterministic quantity?
And what are the
sources of variability
that might cause
the sum of rewards
to differ from one trajectory
to another trajectory?
So one source of variability
is that the state doesn't just
depend on the
action in the state,
but there's also some randomness
that can affect the next state.
Other sources of variability.
So your policy may not
be deterministic either.
So there's two
really key sources.
Here's a good question.
You might have a
stochastic reward function.
So typically we actually
model the reward--
is a very interesting point.
We often typically
model it as a function
and have the source
of randomness
come from states and actions.
Now, if you don't
know the state,
then it could actually be
viewed as stochastic if you only
have the observations.
So if you're doing reward
learning, the question is,
is there stochasticity there?
Typically you'll still model
it as a reward function.
Well, you might not
have full certainty
over exactly what the
reward is, and perhaps you
might want to leverage
that uncertainty
in some ways in the learning
process, that's maybe something
to take offline.
There's some
considerations there.
So the other thing is your
goals might change over time.
And in that case, the
reward function will change.
We'll actually often model that
as a whole different decision
process at that
point if the rewards
change rather than having it
being within the same one.
There are scenarios
where you might
want a nonstationary
decision process, I guess.
And you can actually often put
that randomness into the state
instead of putting it
in the reward function.
Maybe there's some
underlying goal
that you can't observe
that's in the state,
And then the reward function
remains deterministic.
And so yeah, generally
without losing generality,
you can push that into
the state if needed.
Cool.
So the two main
sources of variability
that you have to worry about
are the world is stochastic
so environment is dynamic.
This is a distribution.
It's not a
deterministic function.
And the second is that
the policy is also not
deterministic.
And so in driving, for
example, other cars
are going to behave in
ways that are random,
and your car might not make
the same decision every time.
Cool.
And so if we actually want to
think about maximizing rewards,
we can then add in the
policy into this diagram
where, if you have
access to state,
there would be an
error from here
to here that is modeling
this distribution,
and likewise from here to here.
Now, if we then wanted
to actually write down
what rewards look like, we need
to think about a probability
distribution over trajectories.
You need to think about what
is actually the distribution
over futures that we'll see.
And the way that we can
think about that is we'll
have some initial state.
There may actually
also be randomness here
that we haven't talked about.
The initial conditions of
the world might change.
And if you're like
playing a game,
for example, how the cards
are dealt out will vary.
And then after the
state, you're going
to be making a decision
with your policy.
And then once you
make that decision,
there is randomness that
arises from the dynamic.
And then if we want to think
about the probability of a given
trajectory, is going to be the
probability of the first state,
then the probability of
picking the next action,
observing the next state, then
the probability of picking the
action after that, and then
the next state, and so on.
And so then we can think about
the probability of a given
trajectory as being
the initial state
probability plus the
product of the probabilities
from the policy and
the dynamics where
here t equals 1 to capital T.
And then once we formulate
this probability distribution
over trajectories, then we can
think about maximizing reward
as actually maximizing
our expected rewards
under this probability
distribution.
So we'll think about the
expectation of trajectories
sampled from this distribution
of the sum of state and actions
in this trajectory of the
reward of that state and action.
And then this is our goal.
Our goal is to maximize this.
And our goal is to find a policy
pi that maximizes these expected
sum of rewards, and so
that is written right here.
Now, note that, unlike
in supervised learning,
this doesn't look like
something that you can--
pi actually doesn't even
appear in this equation,
but the way that
it comes in is how
it's affecting the trajectory.
So this distribution of
trajectories is a function of pi
right here.
And you actually want to
find the policy that will
lead to the highest reward.
And a lot of this class
will be figuring out
how do we actually
optimize behavior
under this particular objective.
Now the question is, does
capital T have to be fixed?
It does not have to be fixed.
It can be variable.
It's a little bit easier to
write down if it's fixed.
But yeah, you can
also think about it
as basically the
length of the message.
Yeah.
So one other topic that will
come up in depth a lot more
is when you think
about rewards, this
is weighting the rewards over
the entire trajectory equally,
and it's saying that you
care about immediate reward
just as much as you care
about future rewards.
And in some cases, you might
care about immediate reward
more than future reward.
So for example, if this
T is like 1,000 years,
maybe you don't care so much
about your rewards 1,000 years
from now, then you care
about your rewards today.
And so another way
that you can actually
formulate the reinforcement
learning objective is not just
this vanilla sum of rewards,
but you can actually
weight your rewards by what's
called a discount factor, where
that discount factor actually
depends on T. So one of the ways
we often do that is adding
a discount factor that's
raised to the power of t.
And this means that if a
discount factor-- usually
this is some value
that's greater than 0
and less than or equal to 1.
If this is 1, it's the same
as the original formulation.
And as you make it lower and
lower, you're being more greedy.
You're carrying a lot more
about near-term rewards
than about far rewards.
We'll talk a little bit
more about discount factors
in a couple lectures.
Cool.
As an aside, we've
talked about how
our policy is a distribution,
and so it's not deterministic.
It's stochastic.
Why might we want to do that?
There's a couple reasons
why we might want our policy
to not be deterministic.
The first is that if
you want to learn,
you probably have to
try different things.
If you're learning
how to play tennis,
you probably shouldn't try
the same exact technique
over and over again.
You need to actually explore
and try different strategies
in order to do it.
And so that can be represented
as a stochastic policy that's
trying a few
different strategies
and trying to figure out
which strategy is best.
And then in other cases, there's
scenarios where you collect data
from people or from
different systems,
and those people are taking
different strategies.
And if you want to model the
way that they're approaching
a problem, you may
need your policies
to be stochastic as well.
And for this, we can
also leverage tools
from generative models
where you're actually
thinking about not just a neural
network that maps from A to B,
but actually a generative
model over actions
given states and observations.
I think this is the last thing
we'll touch on and introduce,
which is, how do we
decide how good--
well, OK, second to last thing.
How do we decide how
good a policy is?
And this is really
useful to think about
because if you don't know
how good your policy is then
you're not going to be able
to make your policy better.
And the terminology that
we use to think about this
is referred to as
a value function.
So we often think about
the value function
for a policy of a given
state, and we denote it
typically as V pi of S. And
essentially what this means is,
it's the future expected
reward if you start at S
and then follow pi
from then onward.
And so it's basically
this equation
except starting at S
under your current policy.
And similarly to
this, another thing
that we'll start talking
about, not in Friday's lecture
but starting next week, is
Q value functions as well.
And this is very similar
to the value function.
But instead of actually starting
from S, then taking action a,
and then following pi,
where action a might
be different from what
policy pi might have taken.
I'm not going to go into depth
on what these two functions are
today, but I wanted to
introduce them because we'll
be using them quite a lot.
And so it's good to start
wrapping your head around what
they are as we start to use
them more in future lectures.
And then the types of
algorithms we'll cover.
The idea behind
imitation learning
is to mimic a policy that
achieves high reward.
We'll then next
week start talking
about policy gradients that
try to directly differentiate
this objective
and actually learn
from practice and experience.
From there, we'll talk about
actor critic algorithms that
estimate the value of the
current policy and use that
to make policy better.
We'll talk about
value-based methods that
try to estimate the value
of the optimal policy,
and then use that to
back out a good policy.
And then lastly, we'll talk
about model-based methods that
actually learn how to model
the dynamics of the world,
try to predict the future,
and then use that to improve
the policy or for planning.
Now, you might be
wondering, why do
we have so many different
algorithms for optimizing
this objective?
In supervised learning, we
just have gradient descent.
It works.
It's great.
It's simple.
In reinforcement learning,
things are less simple.
Algorithms make
different trade-offs
and thrive under
different assumptions.
And so it's going to depend on,
for example, how easy or cheap
is it to collect data.
And if you're in a
simulator, for example,
it's really, really
cheap to collect
lots of data versus
if you're handwriting
responses or actually
interacting with a person that's
writing things, that's
going to be more expensive.
Also, how cheap and easy are
different forms of supervision?
Do you have demonstrations?
Do you have detailed rewards?
How important is
stability and ease
of use versus data efficiency?
Maybe you have
more time to change
some of the hyperparameters
if it doesn't
need massive amounts of data.
There's also some
considerations with regard
to what your actions look like.
How high-dimensional are they?
Are they continuous or discrete?
Is it easy to learn
the dynamics model?
So yeah, these are some
of the reasons why we have
a lot of different algorithms.
And we'll be talking
about different algorithms
and where they're applied in
the later parts of this course.
So to recap, there's
a lot of terminology
and a lot of notation in
reinforcement learning,
and wanted to start
introducing them today
because we'll be
starting to use them
quite a bit in the
following lectures.
So we talked about states.
We talked about observations.
We talked about actions,
reward functions, and also
initial state
distribution and dynamics.
These form what's called
a Markov decision process.
Or if you only
have observations,
it's called a
partially-observable Markov
decision process or
an MDP or a POMDP.
I didn't want to bring in this
notation until the very end
because it doesn't actually
really matter what it's called,
but it's useful.
In the long term if people
are referring to MDPs,
now you know what
they're referring to.
They're referring to this
formulation of a reinforcement
learning problem.
And then we also talked
about trajectories, policies,
the objective of
reinforcement learning,
value functions, and
Q functions briefly.